un test pcr ou antigénique négatif en
guise de laisser passer
depuis ce lundi minuit c'est ce que doit
présenter toute personne en provenance
de moselle pour franchir la frontière
vers l'allemagne en cause l'inquiétude
des allemands face aux variants sud
africain très présent dans ce
département français
une décision unilatérale de berlin amer
pour les travailleurs frontaliers
chaque jour seize mille personnes
traversent la frontière pour se rendre
au travail
ça fait 33 ans que je travaille chez
hkdp en allemagne et c'est la première
fois que je vais devoir faire un test
pour aller en allemagne
je comprends pas quand quand je vais
travailler dans une boîte cet après midi
je vais travailler à ce que mes
collègues allemands devront faire le
test
non pourquoi nous les français on va
fêter cette façon ceux qui veulent
passer après ils passeront c'est parce
qu'ils optent en mettre un
on va dire un policier à tous les coins
de rue coin surtout l'or a toutes les
entrées qui a et tout je pense que c'est
pas possible quoi la france a évité la
fermeture totale de la frontière exit
les transports collectifs suspendu